you're just barely as I understand my
research 18 months or so off a road crew
and now you're in Bellevue Washington
getting you gotta you gotta keep really
in mind that it's not me they're coming
out to see it's it's this character that
I play and I'm very very flattered that
it's gone over as well as it haskers
certainly like you said no one expected
that it would but I think it's real good
to know that yeah you know a year ago I
was shoveling asphalt in a year from now
I could be doing it again I think it
keeps a good perspective on things as
long as you remember that well they're
screaming Luke cuz they know that's what
my name is but I don't they don't really
know Luke too well you know they they
know Dylan they know what they see and
they like that and that's a good thing
because I wasn't really sure if Dylan
was a very likable character when I
first got a hold up and started playing
it but the writers you know we get some
really good writers on our show and they
really paid attention to that I don't
think anybody's good all the time I
don't think anybody's bad all the time
and you know luckily I've got to show a
little bit of sides of both the Dylan so
I get mixed reviews you know some people
I go out and they see them they think
are you such a nice guy and other people
are going I should have done that you
shouldn't have done that you know people
are watching that's cool
well as always in television it's hard
to be 100 percent credible because I
don't think the viewing public wants to
see 100 percent of the truth we try to
be as credible as we can and we try to
stick factually to to the material that
you know as much as possible we've done
shows some of our more issue oriented
programs about AIDS
alcoholism teen pregnancy things like
that and when you're dealing with
serious issues like that you have to be
as realistic as possible however there
are some realities that are being
committed out there in the world that
people just don't want to turn on TV and
see that's where somebody's got to draw
the line and say this is what we will do
and this is what we won't as an actor I
don't want to draw any lines I want to
do it all I want to show it all but
the network constraints do not allow
that you know as you guys know not in my
mind but then I don't write them I just
say the words you know they write them
like all television series nano2 will
come and it will go you know there's
gonna come a day when they're gonna say
that's it that's your last episode
before that day comes though I think
that you know we really have to try our
best we have a hold of such a powerful
medium here you know and if you you just
keep putting on you know repeats of or
not necessarily read piece but recycled
scripts of other programs and things
like that I think you're really wasting
a very valuable resource and mr.
Spelling you know Aaron produces the
show who has done a lot of television
people think you know because he's he
hasn't worked in a while he hasn't had a
hit show in a while and he hasn't done
anything that he's getting old and he's
lost his edge I think this show goes a
real long way to prove that you know
that that's not the case at all that guy
you know my he might have a few years on
some of us but that's all you know we
don't have anything on him he's very
aware and he's very he sees what's going
on those the kind of shows we want to
make um we got an airplane as far as the
show getting bigger and bigger more
people are watching it and more people
do know about us but terms of the star
business we start slapping each other
when somebody gets too big-headed you
know we made a promise going into this
we said look guys nobody expects that
we're gonna do anything other than these
13 episodes if by some chance we
surprised the world and put out a
quality program that people want to keep
watching let's remember how we got there
and let's remember what makes the show
so good the show is good and I'll say
that yeah I'm on a good show the show is
good because it's an ensemble piece
everybody works and everybody brings
something to it you know I think the
casting was excellent on the show they
brought everyone brings a different
angle to it and the show works the best
when everyone works and if we all work
together as a team that's what's going
to continue that's what's going to
continue to keep you know the quality of
the program I don't care how many we
make quantity is not an issue
as long as each individual show
everybody tries their hardest and these
guys do sometimes it looks though like
we're laughing so hard we'll never get
anything done but when they say roll and
they say action you got a group of
professional actors there that are
getting the job done and I couldn't ask
for a better working situation
[Music]